MICROSOFT EDGE:
Ah, internet explorer,
the browser you use to download other browsers.
Or at least, that’s what it used to be until
Microsoft finally decided to retire Internet
Explorer in mid 2022. Don’t worry though,
Microsoft has a replacement for Internet
Explorer called Edge, and it’s able to
download Google Chrome even faster. In fact,
it’s able to download it even faster the Chrome
would be able to download it given that it’s
objectively faster. According to Microsoft,
Edge is 112% faster than Chrome, but who knows
what cherry picked data they’re using. Something
that is surprising though is the Edge is actually
faster in real world testing as well. This is
what many blogs have beeng claiming for quite
some time now, and through my personal testing,
it does appear to be true. On BrowserBench,
I was able to get a score of 270 using Edge,
while I only got a score 251 using Chrome. This
wasn’t just a fluke either. Test after test,
Edge consistently scored about 20 points better
than chrome. Edge is not just snappier than
chrome either, it’s also more efficient. With
60 tabs open, Chrome used up 3.7 GB of memory
while Edge only used up 2.9 GB. This will be
quite noticeable for all you who regularly
have dozens of tabs open. I know you’re watching.
Alright, so Edge might be marginally faster and
more efficient than the other browsers, but
speed isn’t the only factor when it comes to
choosing a browser. There’s several other factors
that you might consider such as which one is more
socially acceptable. I’m just kidding, of course
you don’t do that, but what you might consider
is the default search engine. Now technically,
the default search engine on Edge is Bing. But,
Microsoft isn’t hell bent on getting you to
actually use Bing. In fact, you can switch
to Google within literally 10 seconds. But, what
about the hundreds of thousands of extensions that
are available on the chrome web store. Surely,
Microsoft can’t compete with that right? Well,
they don’t have to because they simply let you
use the chrome web store. The new version of Edge
is based on Chromium meaning that you can add
any Chrome extension to Edge. You can also add
Microsoft extensions to Edge as well, not that
Microsoft’s catalog is anything to brag about,
but you do have that as well which simply gives
you even more options. On top of all this,
Edge also has awesome integration with Microsoft
Office and and Outlook for obvious reasons. Edge
also comes with a lot of quirks that many people
really like such as the ability to arrange your
tabs vertically and the sidebar on the side of
the screen. So, really, you get the best of both
the Google world and the Microsoft world. This
is really not that surprising given that Edge is
really just a faster implementation of Chrome with
some Microsoft aspects thrown in here and there.
But, despite this, Edge is getting destroyed
when it comes to market share. Chrome’s market
share stands at a dominating 60% while Edge’s
market share isn’t even able to cross 5%. So,
why does no one want Edge despite it
being equivalent to chrome if not better.
INTERNET EXPLORER:
One of the main reasons that people avoid Edge
like the plague is because of Internet Explorer.
At one point in history, Internet Explorer was
actaully the most popular browser on the planet,
but not because it was good but because it was
forced. You see, before Internet Explorer, people
were perfectly happy using the WorldWideWeb,
Lynx, and of course Netscape. But, in 1995,
Microsoft decided that they wanted a piece of
the internet pie as well, so they came out with
Internet Explorer. And knowing Microsoft, they
didn’t want to leave the adoption of Internet
Explorer up to chance. So, they bundled Internet
Explorer in with Windows. And just as they hoped,
new PC users tended to use the default browser,
Internet Explorer, and this led to the browser
becoming the dominant browser. But Microsoft had
gotten one thing wrong. Just because Internet
Explorer was the most popular didn’t mean that
it was actually popular amongst people. At best,
people had a neutral opinion on the browser
while enthusiasts hated it. This wasn’t to
say that Internet Explorer was terrible. It
got the job done fine, but at the same time,
it wasn’t anything notable either. What really
triggered enthusiasts was the fact that Microsoft
forced Internet Explorer while there were several
other great options. It wasn’t just enthusiasts
that were triggered either. Regulators were
triggered as well. Microsoft was literally
blocking computer manufacturers from putting
any other web browser on the desktop. And this
was after they agreed that they wouldn’t bundle
Internet Explorer in with Windows. As you would
guess, regulators didn’t take this violation
lightly, and this issue would be escalated up
to the supreme court. During the worst of it,
Microsoft was actually being ordered to split
into two different companies. But, luckily for
Microsoft, this order was cancelled at the last
second because the judge issuing the order had
broken protocol by talking to the press. So,
ironically, it was the press that saved Microsoft
at the Supreme Court, but they by no means helped
Microsoft in the public court. By the early 2000s,
the general public was well aware of how Microsoft
had abused their power with IE and they resented
Microsoft for it. For many, Microsoft was the
embodiment of everything that was wrong with a
capitalistic society. So, they started leaving
in droves, and they started supporting an open
source project: Mozilla Firefox. For many years,
FireFox was the go to browser not just for
enthusiasts, but for everyone. By 2010,
FireFox had 33% market while IE had 50% market
share. In fact, if Firefox had a few more years,
they would’ve overtaken IE and became the most
popular browser in the world by far. But, Sundar
Pichai and Google had a different plan. They had
seen quite a bit of success within the search and
email space, and now they wanted to challenge the
likes of Microsoft and Apple with Google Chrome.
GOOGLE CHROME:
While Firefox was giving Microsoft a run for their
money, they had by no means lost the game quite
yet. All of the F Microsofters had already left,
so the people that were left were simply looking
for a functional browser, and Internet Explorer
was more than capable of that. So, all Microsoft
had to do was keep Internet Explorer functional,
but they couldn’t even do that. At first glance,
this might be a bit surprising. Why was a multi
hundred billion dollar company not able to keep up
with a browser? A literal opensource community was
able to do that. Well, the answer is not a lack of
resources, the answer is hubris and arrogance. You
see, Microsoft had never played by the rules, they
were the ones that set the rules. And everyone
else had to follow Microsoft’s rules whether they
wanted to or not because Microsoft had the users.
Microsoft approached IE with the same attitude.
They didn’t give a crap about global web standards
or developers or even putting out consistent
updates. Microsoft was updating IE only once every
few years. While developers were willing to put up
with this BS when IE had 80 to 90% market share,
they stopped catering to Microsoft’s needs
as Firefox and Chrome starting making a name
for themselves. Unlike IE, Chrome was built for
developers by developers. Google figured that to
get end users to switch, they first needed to get
developers to switch and make websites that ran
great on their browser. Fortunately for Google,
this wasn’t that hard to do given that Microsoft
was in hibernation. The results of this weren’t
immediately clear, but about 5 years after the
launch of Chrome in the early to mid 2010s, the
general public started to notice. More and more
websites started to look wonky on IE. People
also started to notice that their friends who
used Chrome experienced less lag, fewer crashes,
and simply had an overall smoother experience.
But IE’s problems stretched much further
than just being slow and displaying websites
poorly. Do you remember how computer viruses were
an actual concern 10 to 20 years ago? Well, one
of the main reasons for that is actually Internet
Explorer. You see, Microsoft allowed developers to
write website code in the international standard
which is Javascript or Visual Basic Script. The
reasoning for this was that VB Script could allow
developers to accomplish more advanced tasks as
they would have greater access to the user’s PC.
But, this also meant that it was way easier to
infect computers with viruses. Let’s just say that
this security issue was so bad that Microsoft has
since put out tutorials on how to disable VBScript
execution. So, not only was IE slower and wonky,
it was a serious security threat. I mean,
it’s almost as if Microsoft was actively
encouraging people to leave IE. And that’s
exactly what they did. Between 2009 and 2015,
IE’s marketshare would plummet from 65% down to
15%. Clearly, Microsoft’s hibernation strategy was
no longer working, and they would finally decide
to do something with the launch of Microsoft Edge.
INTERNET EXPLORER V2:
Microsoft initially launched Edge alongside
Windows 10 back in 2015, but while Edge had a
much more modern look than IE, not much had
changed really changed. Behind the scenes,
Microsoft was making all of the same mistakes
that they were making with IE. For example,
Edge was built on Microsoft’s proprietary
browser engine, EdgeHTML and their Chakra
Javascript Engine. While these sounds fancy, the
reality was that Edge still didn’t support even
basic open media standards such as WebM and Opus.
So, Edge was really just the same crappy Internet
Explorer but with a face lift. We should also
mention that Microsoft was still using their
classic monopolistic practices with Edge as it
came with Windows 10 and now Windows 11 as well.
But, by this point, people had become numb to
Microsoft’s games. Downloading a new browser using
Microsoft’s default browser became a natural part
of buying a new computer. Nobody even bothered
checking out if Edge was actually good or not. In
fact, Edge’s market share was a laughable 2%. But,
no worries, it’s not like any of these people
missed out on anything because Edge still sucked.
This didn’t remain the case forever though as
Satya Nadella, the new CEO, would eventually
come around to addressing Edge. Unlike his
predecessors, Satya didn’t have the pompous
viewpoint that Microsoft was the only and best
choice consumers had. Instead, he acknowledged
their shortcomings and embraced their competitors.
For example, instead of endlessly pursuing the
Windows Phone, he chose to embrace iOS and Android
by launching Microsoft Office on these platforms.
He would carry over this same mindset when it
come to addressing the browser space. Instead
of trying to outshine Chrome by developing
their own advanced browser from scratch,
he chose to embrace Chrome. He acknowledged that
Chrome had won over the users and the developers,
so it was much smarter to build off of Chrome’s
success and simply add a Windows spin to it. And
that’s exactly what happened. At the end of
2018, Microsoft announced that they would be
switching Edge to Chromium. And at beginning
of 2020, Microsoft would launch the new Edge.
THE NEW EDGE:
Since then, Edge has simply become more and
more integrated with Chrome but at the same
time it has also become more and more unique.
For example, they embraced the chrome webstore,
but at the same time, they also addressed
Chrome’s atrocious ram usage. Similarly,
they let you use Google as your default search
engine, but at the same time, you have the full
power of Microsoft’s Office suite which let’s
be honest is way better than Google’s offerings.
Microsoft Edge is no longer the lock into the
Microsoft ecosystem that it once used to be. But,
despite all this, no one wants to switch primarily
because of their negative opinion on IE and the
original Edge. With that being said though, we
can’t expect these types of switches to happen
overnight. Enthusiasts are starting notice, and
as Google becomes the one that’s hibernating,
we may just see a non monopolistic browser
space. Would you be wiling to switch to
Edge? Comment that down below. Also, drop a
like if you’re glad that Chrome may finally
see some competition. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.